okay here's a bit of soil chemistry
so i'm holding this piece of mud that i
just took off
from the surface of the soil and it's
interesting because you see
a brownish layer on top here a thin one
it's about
maybe extends about two three
millimeters deep into the salt on top of
that is actually a bit more greenish
yeah and then underneath of that we have
this dark
gray blackish soil and that's basically
what's happened
happening in the flooded soil it's what
we call a chemical
reaction which is actually driven by
microbial processes
reducing the the iron compounds from
iron two
iron three oxides and hydroxides
which have a reddish color into iron two
compounds which have a grayish
color so what we have up here is
basically a layer where the oxygen
still comes in from the water that we
put on
and though that always stays oxidized
and underneath that we have this highly
anaerobic
reduced soil in which the roots are but
this is also
up here a very biologically active layer
which is why it's greenish on top so
you've got
algae living on top doing nitrogen
fixation and all kinds of things